on february 27th at approximately
midnight a night county sheriff's office
deputy was involved in a fight with a
suspect outside of shenanigan's bar in
param without backup the deputy was
initially parked in the parking lot of
shenanigans on calvada boulevard a man
approached the deputy at his driver's
side window and pointed at him while
recording with his cell phone
the man later identified as joshua
briscoe age 42 of pahrump began asking
the deputy why he was parked there
when the deputy exited his patrol car to
ask if he needed help briscoe continued
cursing and asking why he was parked
there the deputy walked into the bar to
locate security and briscoe followed him
the deputy had to tell briscoe to back
up and physically push him back for both
of their safety as the deputy was
exiting the bar briscoe approached him
from behind in a threatening manner the
deputy attempted to detain briscoe and
he began to physically resist by hitting
kicking and grabbing the deputy's arms
and legs while the deputy was attempting
to restrain briscoe a second male jumped
onto the deputy's back and wrapped his
arm around his neck and began to choke
him
he fled the scene shortly after briscoe
was eventually restrained and placed
under arrest he was booked into the ny
county detention center for battery on a
protected person
anyone with information on the identity
of the second suspect seen in this video
is urged to contact the nye county
sheriff's office at 775-751-7000
or by email at sheriff co.nye.nv.us
[Music]
you